and we're on the air hello everyone
how's everybody you today first I guess
I have to answer a question not merely
my son Hans over there on the other side
all right and and monkey mine asked a
very important question
he was enthused and trawled out of his
mind completely with this banana
dimension they came up yesterday what is
the banana dimension is there an apple
dimension I'm very because today we're
going to talk about rationality and you
mentioned a banana dimension I think
that's a very good introduction to the
subject so ridiculous I mean they talked
about the dimension of mass that
dimension temperature I mean for sure I
just I know yeah but you could right I
mean for all we know Mimi you know when
in a million tests but it's a
possibility anyways today I'd like to
introduce the seventh subject today is
irrationality my son asks why why
rationale why not rationality he says I
get kind of like a chip on the shoulder
on my shoulder which is more little
comment that I use today by just by
sheer coincidence and and yeah the
question is what is rationality I'm
gonna introduce the subject with a topic
that I discussed I think yesterday I
started the threat over there at the
rational scientific group
and it goes something like this
I made a statement the statement is in
relation to the fact that they shot a
bear polar bear in Norway ships carrying
tourists they must by law carry to bear
guards a beard guard is a guy with a
machine gun a bazooka I don't know it he
carries a gun and if a bear approaches
the tourists he's supposed to do justice
Norway so the so so it turns out that
two of these bear guards they come down
on small bird island and they know
there's some wild animals there among
them bears and these two guys walk
around there and a bear pounces on one
of them and hurts him in the head they
didn't give the details they say it
wasn't life-threatening but the bear
pounced upon him started mauling him and
the other guy shot the bear dead maybe
he was shooting his own friend for all I
know I mean you know but he shot the
bear dead and so animal lovers you know
they get a little upset that you know
that they had to kill this I mean isn't
there a better way of treating animals
and I went on the other side completely
I'm on the other side of conservationism
people don't like that but I suggest
that we killed deliberately all big
animals on earth let me say that again I
suggest and propose this is a political
statement by the way it's got nothing to
do with science okay we'll get there in
a second this is just the introduction
I'm saying that we're supposed to kill
all dangerous animals on earth all big
animal wolves bears lions tigers hyenas
what do we need them for and so the
first issue is you know when someone
like no sharks he goes I mean we name
whole bunch of them in fact they do yeah
yeah yeah yeah kill them home I mean
what do we need them for you suggesting
kill all animals do
perfect perfect we don't need them
they're not part of our economy
in any way shape or form they're just
there for tourism we go to Kenya and
when doing Safari to watch the worst
spectacle that you could possibly watch
a lion eating in front of a bunch of you
know they have all these jeeps there and
all the people are taking their cameras
out and they're filming and here's the
line tearing a part of poor wildebeest
or a poor Buffalo that's actually pretty
gangster a person mauling a person you
wouldn't have a crowd of people just
taking pictures they would try to get
the guy off of them right but here they
see the blood that's coming on guys can
you help yeah we don't we don't help the
Buffalo and our logic because we are
rational individuals our logic is that
well the lion has to eat and here we are
we're seeing this this beautiful animal
this beautiful Buffalo and the lion
brings him down sometimes some male line
he does all by himself he doesn't even
need a group of lionesses or whatever so
he bring him down and it takes him a
long time to bring this animal down so
so there's a big struggle sometimes I
heard of one case it took like 24 hours
for a male lion to bring down a buffalo
24 hours the two animals were struggling
and the lion had bit the shins of the
back shins of the of this Buffalo and
and he was in Buffalo was still quite
strong
after 24 hours he was just quite tired
they were both tired but the guy was
filming just filming and filming and
filming saying you know how nice how
beautiful nature and so I'm the
irrational this right because I say that
we should kill all these animals and so
people questions say you know Bill has
lost his mind he's cuckoo right is he
rationally logical is the
reasoning I mean how can he say such
idiotic things well that's the point
I don't think I'm being emotional when I
say it I'm saying I think we should kill
them because first we're not in the
Paleolithic Age and that's the point you
know you're not being emotional at all
right right and that's you I wasn't used
to that
in fact I was accused of that today
young it's a yeah but I think it's the
opposite I think it's inhumane to let
them live listen to what I'm gonna say I
think it's inhumane to let them live why
because we had 150,000 lions about 50
years ago we only have 30,000 today this
is a species that is dying slowly dying
what a conservationists do they go out
there and they try to save the lion you
know save the Panda save the koala bear
whatever any animal that's close to
extinction or is in danger becoming
extinct Oh save it no we should kill it
what we're watching now is many animals
becoming X in many species becoming
extinct we're in the sixth mass
extinction we're undergoing it lots of
species have lived their full term
they're dying in front of us that's the
way I see it at least and there's
nothing we can do about it great measure
because they lost their genetic
diversity and their population pyramid
is obviously going to overturn we're not
helping by crowding them out by
squeezing them in corralling them as I
call it you know we say nature it's not
nature nature's what we head into
Palaeolithic that was nature a pristine
garden what we have today is Corral's we
enclose these lines say okay this is
where you can live will allow you to
live there it's like a cattle farm but
it's just a little bigger you know the
Serengeti what is that it's it's a it's
an enclosure we can't go in there they
can't come out so they're like enclosed
in their will kind of box them in it's a
big zoo it's a big zoo that's all it is
and and we have the illusion that we are
doing you know nature that we're
allowing nature to take its course no
we're not we're essentially watching
these animals
I like you would watch your cattles
Diana form slowly you know the herd
shrinking well what I'm saying is the
following and I gave the example today
of the the what is it the Tasmanian
target Tasmanian tiger the last two one
died in captivity in the zoo in 1936 I
think it was 34 there abouts and the
other one was shot in the wild by a
farmer the apparently the this animal
which carries a pouch
he's a marsupial which was the last one
I I think it was the one in the zoo died
later this one was shot in the wild
saying he was shot then that means
bullets caused the extinction yeah also
the other one died of old age so they
died of old age yeah I guess but the
point is you know they you you kind of
feel sorry for these animals because
they're the last two of their breed and
it's like they can't even find a friend
out there a a girl to mate with or they
could have been female for all I know I
don't remember now but or a mate you
know they're the last of their species
and it kind of makes you it's very
philosophical
makes you wonder a lot you say should we
allow tigers or Lions or whatever to
reach that same status where they slowly
die we can't help them we cloned them we
do all these things and we keep dying on
us and finally we end up with the last
to the last one the last zero I mean to
me it's it's like watching a person die
slowly and the guy says please kill me
and I say well I can't kill you because
I go to prison dr. Kevorkian dr. K there
isn't please kill me yeah yeah baby okay
the analogy is that perfect all I'm
saying is I think it's it's sad to watch
you know
a species died slowly that's that's one
issue the other one as these animals are
dangerous yeah you know you go into the
ocean and a shark grabs you know you say
oh how nice the Sharks except when they
grab your foot and then they're not so
nice same with an alligator or a
crocodile you put your foot in the river
and suddenly you know something grabs
you and pulls you and you say no no I
don't like Crocs
you know what's too late but there's a
difference between lions and sharks
because we don't know what their role is
well tigers we know more about tigers
and lions Bobby we know more about the
effects of their absence then we knew
the show might get some crazy
you'd be surprised but we know quite a
bit about the Sharks as well because we
know what they eat and how they control
the oceans also yeah no not necessarily
because if we get rid of the Sharks and
I don't know the barracudas are now
multiplying then we kill the Barracuda
if we have no use for them and so on
down the line we have to kill the
animals yeah it sounds like a lot of you
limit the population you you kind of
shrinking until you hopefully get it
down to zero I mean why don't we need
beric yeah yeah we barracudas do we know
them on our own again we're still
talking about the ecosystem and then you
kill those as well until we only have
humans or cows and cows all being said
what we love something else something on
the food chain right and that's the
point the point is whoever is not part
of our food chain when we need them for
what do we need to live with for sure a
lion is not portable we don't know what
some are obvious okay let's start with
the Lions gonna give you kill all the
bees we have a problem right right so we
don't we don't kill the bees because
they pollinate we do help us what about
the things that easily
these are the things that bees you know
but that's my point my point is we do a
study when you say look we have no use
for alligators except for luggage yeah
let's put an alligator farm or a croc
farm and and and that's what we'll use
the Crocs for but if we have no use if
we find that we have no use for the
Crocs they kill them what do we need why
do we need this dangerous among us
there's no just in case I mean today if
we know that we have no use for Crocs we
don't know if you know this time no one
can't come up and says look I think I'm
gonna have a croc front which they do
that by the way they have croc forms a
dish about farming I'm talking about
what part what role the row they in the
ecology yeah I know I hear that's a
different thing than just they're just
directly meetings we we might indirect
me anything we have studied a lot of
these animals we we knew a lot about the
food chains okay we that's like seven
years ago we can removed all the B's and
then we wouldn't you could be in trouble
then we just wouldn't have certain
things you know we don't know we know
that now
no but we don't even know that we kind
of just assumed that we don't really
we're not sure ecology is a huge like
God complicated [ __ ] right they're
getting really lightweight like if
there's only two lions or one lion they
feel that guy there's not gonna be a
difference in the ecology but if we kill
all the eggs there's a big population of
its ecology that's gonna have different
that's different than just killing the
last koala for example yeah and again we
would have to do a study find out as
much as you can do is doing it and
that's
that's true also and I'm sure and I'm
sure that that's not gonna affect but my
point here is the following so my
rationale that's the question am i a
rational individual if I suggest I mean
you know if you want different theories
you came to the right place because you
know I'm proposing the rope hypothesis
for light and gravity and you know
magnetism and so on and these people are
proposing particles and waves I propose
that the Neanderthals did not die
because they intermarried with humans
and that's the status quo today that's
the reigning theory I do not accept that
an asteroid killed the dinos they died
in a different way like all other mass
extinctions as a result of food the
ecological pyramid turned on them and
that's not what orthodoxy says and you
know insane here you know you want a
real weird theories you came to the
right place and does that make me an
irrational list I mean should we all
vote should we all vote and say well
Bill's an irrational individual because
he's against this against 99% of
humanity against that 99.9 and so on
that should be boat for rationality we
vote for Russia well maybe that's the
precious is we call it common should it
work that [ __ ] should it work that way
you're saying what do you mean by should
like is it official to consider
rationality put a statement made by mr.
Leonard Susskind Leo Susskind he's from
Stanford University and he says the
folly which is very perked I was gonna
say it later but you brought up the
subject now you're stuck with it and he
says the following he says modern
science is difficult and often
counterintuitive where intuition and
common sense failed they had to create
new forms of intuition mainly through
the use of abstract mathematics no
kidding when common sense fails uncommon
sense
must be created human cognition does not
operate according to principles of
common sense so so they created a new
common sense it used to be common sense
was what common people thought were the
maturity and he's saying we had to
create a new common sense based on
mathematics of course why because we
couldn't explain anything we couldn't
justify things and so we had to get into
this world in which you know common
sense had to change the least common of
all senses yeah so the question should
we vote for common sense I mean yeah
common sense by definition what I'm
saying is rationality should we vote for
a rationality is rationality something
we define or it's something we
democratic where we all vote arrays are
kind of a point where there are some
things that are counterintuitive we have
that phrase counterintuitive because it
happens more than what it's happened a
few the counterintuitive phenomena where
Perry's not things are not paradox if
things are the way you think they
wouldn't be things are the way you think
they wouldn't be like like you see it's
a common trend in YouTube videos these
life hack videos okay or they where they
show we call it common ways okay doing
this way but more effective that's the
thing well even if it's less a vacant
way is always more effective more
effective way isn't the straightforward
way that you just magic tricks are like
that also you know how you do things
they're different way you've actually
done isn't the way you think it was done
right we have this phrase
counterintuitive because it comes up so
often but
so good that's a good kind of piece of
this puzzle of common sense slash
rationality slash long huh okay but then
then again is it something we vote for
that's that's the issue because if if
I'm crazy of an irrational I'm illogical
or unreasonable or any word you want to
use to clarify to qualify me because I
hold theories arguments opinions
different than 99% of humanity what
should we do with me put me in a
nuthouse and say well you're crazy right
but the question is is this rationality
something we vote for and say we we hold
the trial and we have a jury and say
okay if 11 people vote against you
you're 12 of them or whatever you know
I mean how should we decide or should we
define what rationality is I think no no
no I say I say that when we say
something is correct or incorrect when
we say that something is right or wrong
when we say that something is true or
false that's an opinion that's a belief
but when we say that something is
rational it is no longer an opinion
because again and the reason I say it's
not is that it's not gonna be subjective
we define it we don't vote for it and
say well we think bill is crazy no no
yeah if you do it that way I mean if the
entire Flat Earth Society votes against
me then I'm irrational no doubt about it
but but if instead if instead we define
it objectively
that's us soon we could define the word
rationality or irrational I like I
prefer to redefine that would let's
assume that we can define it then all we
have to do is follow the definition say
well what does the definition say let's
just apply the deficit let's go by spec
if you want to define it objectively
assume we could well that's assuming you
wanted to well let's do this let's
assume let's assume let's assume I'm a
real
talking objective definition is better
than the subject yeah by God the
objective okay so so let me define rash
rationality or irrationality it doesn't
matter when is the negative the other
idea opposite I'm gonna define
irrationality so that people understand
let me just say it up front
objects are unimaginable that's in your
rationality if you're gonna do physics
especially right if you propose an
object that you cannot even imagine
that's in your rationality right there
objectively you can say well I can't
imagine it but I'm gonna propose it
anyways no no no I'm just first I'm just
gonna mention the three criteria that I
use for irrationality one is proposing
objects that are unimaginable that's an
irrational proposal second using
undefined words or not using them
consistently in other words you define
it one way and then use it differently
throughout your presentation and the
third one that your theory your
explanation doesn't follow from your
assumptions okay those three criteria
those are the one I'm gonna mention real
quick here I'm just mentioning age 45
here here I put it up there okay so I
just mentioned it right now now I'm
gonna give you some examples etc yeah
that's what I'm putting here though
here's the first here's the first one
all right I'm doing one by one here's
the first one treating concepts as
objects that's the main one it's not
only an imaginal object it's that people
turn love into heart that's the problem
right and so we say love moves Mountain
or transferring energy what do you mean
you transferred energy energy is not an
object so you're treating this concept
as an object you can say you transfer to
a rock but you can't say you transferred
love or energy or mass because those are
concepts moving a mass carrying a force
a zero the point particle there's no
such object as a zero the important part
please draw it put it show him show me
on the blackboard what your
throw me something that I can imagine
basically show me a video that I can
play in my head or show me a picture
you know because essentially what we're
saying is an object is an image of
something you can present the object
itself you know a statue of it a mock-up
or whatever or you can draw it and say
look this is a rock okay or whatever and
so I look at this okay I know what the
word Rock means it means that thing
you've got there
but if I say 40 space-time you know four
dimensions but what am I gonna draw and
in fact they tell you that it's
unimaginable and so we got a problem
with that because they're already
starting their whole presentation with
an irrationality okay that's the first
one second one in fact here here I'll
mention a couple more which are very
common yeah I'd like to put these up one
is the electromagnetic wave there's no
such physical object called a wave and
what they draw is a bunch of vectors
there those arrows are vectors they come
out of an axis which is an abstract
straight line that's all it is
and they put it together and you see
them say well I see an object there no
you're not seeing looking at it you're
not staring at an object you're staring
a bunch of arrows which come out of an
axis the arrows are also vectors they're
just representations of vectors they
quote call one of them the electric
field what is a field yesterday we
discussed this it's just a value a
number and so we end up with a total
abstraction which they did which they
pictorially represent with with what you
see in front of you okay but here's here
it gets worse only here here's a mister
I always forget his name's Roger Penrose
okay Roger Penrose and he puts what is
known as a wave packet that's his
illustration in his book that's a wave
packet guys it's an arrow that has
pierced a bed spring that's what it is
so now you know where we packed it looks
like okay I just make sure you don't
touch that tip because it might hurt you
in other words this is a vector and I
don't know and suppose the piercing and
electromagnetic wave that is oscillating
up and down and has a different a pair
a different amplitude as you go from
beginning to end this is absolute
nonsense but this is what they draw and
they draw it because they want to show
you something
they say well we can't really illustrate
a wave packet but look just for the sake
of argument this is a wave packet and
they show you this and you say what the
hell am i staring at so these are all
irrational objects we can't say that
this is the mediator of light and we
cannot say that that is the mediator of
light either neither one of these two is
a mediator of light okay so that's the
first one the second one is like I
mentioned inconsistent or undefined were
inconsistent definition or undefined
word that's the second criteria the
second specification right for
irrationality you don't define your term
and the most famous example I can think
of is both for a space-time in black
holes they say that both of these are
objects you'll hear that word object
four-dimensional space-time is an object
lalalalala black hole is an object in
space
blah blah blah blah whatever okay so
what is an object well you they never
define the word object that's the first
problem but assuming they did define
that they usually define it as that
which you can start your see what can
you touch or see a black hole I mean
they say that no light comes out of a
black hole so we can't see it we can't
touch it because it's zero zero volume
so we can't touch or see it but it's a
black hole as an object and the
definition of object is touch or see or
the criteria for it the most popular one
and so we got a problem because you know
[Music]
to say that a black hole is an object
and then just leaving it up to the
individual to think well you know I know
what an object is no no please define
what an object is because it's critical
to what you just stated and the other
one is you know again using energy as a
concept you define it as a concept and
and then you I'm sorry you use it as an
object you say what is it what is energy
it's a concept what does it mean it
means the ability or the capacity to
blah blah blah blah blah whatever
okay the capacity that's a property and
then they say I'm gonna move now energy
from A to B I'm gonna transfer energy
from it you move the
pasady you transfer the capacity what
what does that mean and so this is where
the irrationality comes in and again I
think these criteria are objective and
the last one number three is that the
theory is inconsistent with or doesn't
follow from the assumptions case I
always use you know you the detective
comes to the mansion sees a body on the
floor with a knife stuck to his to to
her back I'll make it a woman okay so
the prosecutor starts and presents the
knife in court and says Exhibit one the
knife this is we you know he presents
that as an exhibit because he's gonna
insinuate or suggest to the court to the
jury that this knife is what killed the
person and then his theory his case is
about you know the bullet that broke the
you know the victims skull you say hold
it you presented a knife in your
theories about guns and bullets so you
know it's inconsistent with the
assumptions and that's a just a patently
obvious case but you got other cases
mathematics for sure what's a point well
they draw a dot and you say okay I see
what a point is it's that little circle
that you just drew okay I know the word
point means that and then they use it as
a location or as a number throughout the
presentation another one triangle is
defined that's a two-dimensional
Euclidean space and then we have
Lobachevsky and who has it riemann
labott Chesky put on his saddle and has
a saddle shaped triangle riemann put it
on a sphere he had a spherical triangle
and you say hold it's a plane attract
the word triangle means plane and saw a
plane figure and these guys are twisting
it and calling it units like taking a
cube or better still a square tilting it
creating you know that that sensation
where the this thing is disappearing
it's becoming a rectangle and continuing
to call it a square saying well I'm
tilting the square as soon as you move
it a single inch sideways you no longer
have a square and and these are going to
talk about
three dimensional triangle right right
and this is this is the issue the issues
that all these this is where the
irrationality is and that's why you know
I define it but when you look up the
word irrational yeah I gave criterion
and again the best the best the best
stuff no I do have a definition I'm
saying and again it just harps upon the
main criteria and the main criteria is
as follows using concepts as objects
that is irrational reification same
thing but but the main one that's uses
usually concepts as object at least in
this day and age and as you know I
suggested Max Born said you know we
became more and more abstract and so
they started using concepts more and
less objects they don't even deal with
objects today in mathematical physics
well here's the definition you'll find
in the dictionary this is where the word
irrational without the Faculty of Reason
deprived of reason without are deprived
of normal mental clarity or sound
judgment not in accordance with reason
okay so the key word there is reason we
look at the Wikipedia they have more or
less the same thing but you find the
word rationality is the quality or state
of being rational I love that definition
rationality is the quality or state of
being rational right and and that is
that is being based on or agreeable to
reason okay so again they use the word
reason rationalize the confirmative ones
beliefs with ones reasons to believe and
one end of one action one's actions with
one's reasons for action and others that
you act according to your reasoning but
reason is well let's find out and so I
looked up the word reason also in the
Wikipedia and here it is reason is the
capacity for a consciously making sense
of things but the word sense
this reason which means rationality so
making say what do you mean making say
well that means that you're reasonable
[Laughter]
stick-in-the-mud you know yeah but see
what what yeah because then they accuse
you of being a devil's advocate but
here's the issue the issue is that then
you get to the mathematicians and all
these people who say well you can't
really define any term in the dictionary
because to define them you need other
words and for those you need other words
and this is where they get it you say
well what is rationality rationality
reason okay what is reason reason is
making sense was what is making sense
well this rationality or who knows what
logic and so you just keep getting the
runaround with all these words because
they never learn how to define words
scientifically that's why I come up here
and say look I'm gonna define
rationality whether you agree with me or
not at least you know my version of
rationality or irrationality I'm saying
that irrationality specifically is using
concepts as objects that's in physics
but there are other criteria
unimaginable
undefined words that you know Theory
inconsistent with the assumptions those
are other criteria and and yes so so
what is the issue the issue is that I do
propose at least let me put myself back
in here I do propose a an objective
corrective criteria for defining
rationality or irrational so then we can
use it consistently so we can say look
bill is irrational or rational this
distinction between definition and
criteria you kind of have that but that
is a definition for the word object what
I'm saying that these we could we can
use that as a definition just seems like
like you just pull it out of here but
look right there is like okay from now
on if it doesn't meet this criteria we
don't call it that
I like a link criteria is a very very
straightforward binary and objective
also in that sense
a sense that at least its objective with
respect to the criteria whether you
follow that it follows from the criteria
of the established places the criteria
we give it we all agree with this
criteria let's just go off go with this
if it has this criteria we call it that
if it doesn't have such an intelligent
creature you know you can make that list
yeah yeah you don't have to get to
because these are the three big ones
right I would say that that I totally
agree with that I don't I haven't looked
beyond this I think I had another one
coming in in my mind sometime back but
it's like I didn't dwell dwell too much
on it because I think these three pretty
much cover I would say ninety to ninety
nine percent of the cases that we can
all more or less rationalize things and
say you know is this guy being rational
for example yesterday we talked about
mr. Sean Carroll and he comes up and
talks about fields and how fields
mediate gravity and how fields mediate
magnets and so you say well what is a
field now you asked him for the
definition so he says it's a value at
each point in space around a magnet
around the earth in the case of gravity
fine perfect
will you mean a value well yeah there's
there's a value there's a potential
there's a certain strength at this point
a different strength here different to
think that okay fine we understand the
definition we know what a field is all
these points there how does that produce
a mechanism physical mechanism of
attraction and that's where he fails so
there's no logical consistency no
rationality when when we use his own
definitions to try to explain attraction
or action at a distance and of course
you know he says you know we we we don't
understand it very well of course he can
he'd never understand it if he defines
one thing and uses something else later
on and again that's inconsistency
between theory and assumptions if
definitions if if he's using his in
conditions inconsistently he's defining
it as a concepts in a value at each
point in space and then use it as a
physical object or he says look I'm
gonna explain how a magnet attracts
another one he says I'm gonna put a
field in there okay so he's throwing in
an object and they say oh by the way
it's a concepts in abstract concept so
how does that abstract concept bring two
solid objects together so that's where
the irrationally comes out it comes into
and he can't say he's a rational
individual that and I'm sure he's gonna
not gonna like that a bit yeah cuz it
sounds like like saying you're crazy
it's criteria I think all definition all
definitions are simply a list of
criteria that we go through
yeah like doc no no I'll give you an
example I'll give you the best example
possible the word object in the word
object again what are the criteria and
and here are the here the brainstorming
throughout time see touch criteria I'm
just talking about great to your
specification I thought we define C
touch mass volume motion right those are
the main ones and I'm saying shape so
people say oh tell me bill what is shape
we don't need to understand what shape
is to the high degree all we have to do
is compare shape against motion is say
shape the same thing as motion animation
theory right is it a better criteria we
are what are we using physics are we
gonna use motion as the definition are
we going to use so it's the criteria
that we're use is its I mean it goes
back to what you talk about when you try
to make a definition it's possible right
it's really what you're trying to say is
let's get the least amount of criteria
that cuts off everything that we don't
call this word or make it black and
white but criteria by definition is
I can correct it so off yes forgive when
you're trying to make a definition
concise as short as possible you're
really trying to do is using the least
amount of criteria the least amount of
bullets least amount of checks that you
have to go through with every word to
cancel out all the things that you don't
call that word prevent people from from
going on tangents to bringing up devil's
advocacy extreme Devils advocacy you
know this kind of thing like the guy
says you know if you got a long
definition like you look up the
definition of what science is or the
definition of the term scientific method
you'll find you know a whole paragraph
and so you know the devil's advocate can
pick you to the pieces there you said
well how about this word here and what
do you mean by this you know you got all
this criteria all these commas and
periods and semicolons and you say to
the guy look scientific science would
excite us rational explanations period
done now the guy you know he's gonna
have to struggle the fight against that
you know and and I don't create just a
Korean problem creating it to exclude
all the noise there's too much noise in
the definitions interesting criteria
when it comes to definitions because if
you take the example earlier with
rationality right they didn't really
give a criteria so it wasn't a relation
that's that's how it isn't a definition
when when you have a circular definition
all that means is you haven't given it a
criteria yeah it's like a function in a
code they're still looking for what it
is but their excuse their excuse is that
words are needed to define words but
they're always using Center that's where
you use the argument criteria to cut
through all that because you don't it's
not words it's really just criteria what
criteria do we think same thing when you
talk about life when you try to define
the word like not really really what
you're trying to do is look for the
criteria under which we call life
correctly what do we call life you show
everything that falls under this try to
get the least amount
criteria that still you know gets
everything you call life and excludes
everything you don't call life as really
are you trying to do so you just get the
least amount of criteria that kind of
covers the word it gets rid of the noise
yeah but this this this the definition
for rationality is very telling any
circular definition all it basically
does is spew a bunch of word useless
words because it's not giving any
criteria that we can kind of check off
to use the word consistently that's one
issue the other one is we got to show
the distinction here the the one thing
that opposes the other what these people
are using are synonyms you know what is
rationality reason what is reason logic
what is logic common sense common sense
right in in the other one is what you
mentioned what do we oppose against that
we oppose you know criteria
instead of using synonyms use criteria
and the criteria can't be the same word
can't be a synonym it's got to be a
criteria yeah it's a different word it's
a different word you can write I mean
you can't say okay the dog is that it's
a dog yeah okay yeah yeah great what do
we learn
yeah love as low as low can we use a
different word different criteria about
what criteria is only our criteria we're
saying with other words what can we what
can we compare this word to I mean what
is it criterion let's start there well
criterion is again a price like a
property of that word like the main
property the main characteristic the
main the thing that identifies it unit
you know it's it's that keyword that
gives you a sense of what what are you
talking about like if I say object
I like that word because because yeah
I'll take this in a synonym of shape
shape it's not that's right shape is the
criterion for the primary and only I'd
say interesting is the only criterion
for but it's not a synonym
that's so weird right whereas and again
mess is not a not a synonym of object
volume is not a synonym of about you 3d
is not a synonym for object see touch
motion none of those are criterion for
out those are synonyms but they're
criteria but then you choose the best
criteria which criterion are we going to
use among they can be torn apart real
easily aside from that but the point
here is that what we're proposing is
criteria which of these criteria are we
going to use to define or to say well we
know what an object is because this is
the key property the key the thing that
gives it its main characteristic or it's
only characters object is a good one
because if you do use the criterias
touch for example yeah object is is
everything is things that you can touch
that's the only criteria then you can't
talk about you can't call a black hole
in object because you can't touch it you
can't touch I can't break it let's the
star on the other side of the universe
we can't call Neptune an object right
and that's fine if that's how you want
to use the word no but what they would
say is look you know the we observed saw
you see right how the asteroid touched
Saturn fine we can't see or touch a star
on the other side of the universe period
yeah and so is it the word star an
object are we gonna say well those these
stars that we can see in touch or see at
least those are object but the word star
you know that's star that's any other
outside of you that's not an object we
can't do that we can't see or touch it
so again you know there's many ways of
debunking some of these theory of these
definitions all you can do is say which
is the best criterion among all of these
and that's what we're doing here so that
that was a good point that you mentioned
that that these are all criteria I think
that's where they get into these huge
debates and they say well this one
doesn't reproduce that one doesn't eat
that one doesn't breathe air and unites
a tricky word you're trying it because
you because what you're trying to do
when you're defining it when trying to
list out all the least amount of
criteria for life and you're trying to
exclude rocks and robots right
somebody's trying to keep you know
bacteria fish you know things that
moving so that you know what we call
life it's the right amount of words or
what's the right criteria to exclude
rocks and robots normally we're
excluding robot and we want to include
all these weird and bacteria have
different properties and criteria than
alligators and birds right they lay eggs
they don't you know aerobic life doesn't
yeah yeah air kills it so we can't say
well it's something that breathes well
this guy doesn't breathe you know air
kills it weird is a virus it's a
molecule yeah it has almost all the
right properties but we still don't call
that life so you know again criteria is
the what we have do so so rationality or
irrational isn't that something we vote
for it's something we define once we
define we can apply it to a person and
say look you're rational or you're
irrational what is the weight so you're
saying if we define if we give these
three main criteria yeah to the word
irrational yeah then the theory is
efficient to basically debunk or or you
call it
shut up any thing we actually do call it
rational the way I look is this way we
got to go in two steps here I use the
criteria right we got three criteria
here okay and we say first to the
physicist who's out there the present
presenter the guy who's giving the talk
we say that theory because of this these
criteria it's rational or irrational
right but I can give a presentation
talking about a special relativity or
quantum mechanics or whatever I don't
accept that but I can give the
presentation and people say the theory
you just gave is irrational okay
we're attacking the theory we're saying
we're qualifying the theory we're seeing
the theory is irrational
does that mean I'm irrational no I'm
just giving the presentation I'm
explaining a theory of someone else's
theory and saying this is what general
relativity says but if I believe the
theory if this is my fear this is my
propose I'm saying this is what I
believe in this is what I want you
people to to accept and you know you
know that this is the the proposal for
how the universe works
now I'm irrational as an individual
that's my boy well someone irrational is
kind of it's it's about like talking
about the word infinity instead of
incessant it's just you're applying it
to the wrong thing you can't really talk
about irrational people well you
shouldn't I think the word irrational
rational should be reserved the problem
is that you know we introduced a lot of
everyday ordinary speech stuff and we
say oh he's a very rational guy he's a
he's a reasoning guy we we give him
kudos you know the matter boys he's a
logical yeah he's either logical or
illogical and so so the the problem is
we say this guy is very rational very
logical very commonsensical
we use those terms to qualify
person and what I'm saying is if we're
gonna get into that territory and use it
bring it into science say well Joe just
gave this idiotic presentation he's a
rational guy no he's not a rational guy
because he said something stupid he goes
and so if the theory is irrational and
the guy and someone else qualifies that
guy is rational or commonsensical or
whatever or reasoning or logical that's
where you got to step in and say look
this guy is an irrational guy and here's
the criteria well otherwise we gotta
stick to what he said a minute ago and
that's just let's use the word rational
irrational to the theory yeah cuz he'll
people want to call each other
because then you get today about that I
mean someone tells a funny joke the joke
is funny what if he tells 520 jokes he's
funny it's kind of like what you call
the person is just kind of what they do
that's an opinion theory no doubt about
it's more objective what I hate is when
people come in there and say oh uh you
know Joe is rational joe is irrational
well if he said something stupid you
can't say that he's also rational yeah a
lot of things yeah it is but because
people bring politics into it they they
bring their opinions they bring their
believes and that all stays at the door
[Music]
not quite because your friend starts
everyone's opinions are at the door not
quietly not quite because see all these
guys get medals get money so there's a
yeah that's all politics are yeah i
agree with what at a conference all
money all eagle there's no saying the
medals i read my authority my medal
the gold medal I wanna deal at the what
is it at the no the prize of the what's
the main prize in science no no well he
brings his Nobel medal in there he says
oh I've got Authority and there are no
doctors in a scientific conference no no
there's only ministers no degrees no
medals our authority no voting no
democracy no opinions
no beliefs right it's a weird zone yeah
it's a very limited just objective
objective fanatically objective is the
way it should be I just explained a
mechanism so that people understand it
period it's a very inhumane I mean but
not in humane malice but inhumane like
like inhuman like Burma devoid of
emotion devoid of egos devoid of title
very hard to do among human you and I
think I'm being rational and logical and
it's so rational my own we all we all
have this problem we all fall into that
hole but the issue is yeah maybe you're
right maybe the word rational irrational
should be reserved exclusively for
theories and we just treat them
objectively look you look you failed
here you fail criterion number one you
you didn't have a valid object or you
failed criterion number two you have a
good definition or you use your
definition consistent you're the third
one you know your theory didn't follow
for a mere assumption because if you're
trying to call me up the guy irrational
or is they calling him names I think
it's it's understood wink-wink
nudge-nudge that no no way no but the
guy takes it upon himself look your
theory is irrational what does that mean
you're saying that he's it around
everything is literal
there's no if you know what I mean the
words if you know what I mean you know
what I mean you use irrational your your
it's that's the idea today I like that
the way you put that because it's
criteria and I kept saying and I'll have
to look at it a little harder that it's
it's the definition but I think my son
is correct here its criteria criteria
criteria or a criterion and then it's
quite objective and you don't and that's
one and the other one is criteria is
opposite to sin in him because criterion
I can't say it's an antonym but it's a
word that it's not a synonym and what
these people as you can see here for the
word rationality if rationality is
reason and reason is common sense and
common sense is logic and and so on what
we're doing is essentially using
different kinds of synonyms to qualify
rationality whereas as you say look
rationale rationality rationally using
concepts as objects then it's straight
or unimaginable objects on it or you
haven't defined your terms or you're
using them inconsistently then it's a
straight forward then you don't have to
worry about my opinion you can't say
that
oh my opinion is that you're irrational
no your your what you just said is
irrational by definition what is the
definition of these set of criteria I
think a lot of all scientists should
really be doing programming because
programming really teaches you how
logical logic really can be can't be
allow you put a criteria together stay
with it literally you put it in the
infant if-then and the computer's gonna
take your work no no we
Computers a robot this yeah you kind of
have to know few yes to do science as if
you were doing I like the computer
that's good it's a machine you can't
cheat it you can't cheat it's not gonna
misunderstand right he's gonna
understand exactly what you tell him if
you call this this is then this is a
duck as the junkies this guy there's no
if you say there's a beak has wings and
is white then it's not the white huh
anything that's red it's not gonna see
as a duck anything that doesn't have
wings it's not gonna see it's a duck
right if something has these three you
got to stick to those credit it's gonna
call that a duck it's just very
straightforward love it yeah and that's
what yeah maybe computers should do all
this this this deciding whether a theory
is rational or not we just punch it in
say rationality concepts as objects
can't use them okay so you you program
the computer that way now the other guy
says well I'm gonna be transferring
energy and the computer goes how come
well because you know you violated the
definite the criteria yeah I like that
there is a different logical means that
it follows from the premises
whereas irrational again it's a poorly
defined but I'm defining it here I'm
saying you know there are criteria you
know if you use a in well there it's
again it's illogical to use concepts as
objects right it's your rash it's not it
doesn't follow the logic doesn't follow
I think that's the difference because
logic with logic is just this follows
from that falls from that yeah well with
rational you give it to more criteria
well no it's added more criteria to call
it rational yeah yeah logic what follows
from the other is logical whereas the
other one is just criteria you don't
match the criteria then it's on or off
it's black or white I reject it all you
did is
you added two more criteria to call it
rational because logical is I gotta
think a little more deeply about the
word logical has the third criteria they
use and that's it
that it doesn't follow from the
assumptions from the assumption well the
word rational the way you define it it
has two more criteria so is that we
understand something could still be
logical but not be rational for example
in other words oh I see what you're
saying okay you're right because I got a
smart kid here
if the theory follows from the
assumptions then it's logical right
because that's the notion we have of
logic that it follows from the premises
you know the from the axioms but if you
have the wrong objects or you don't have
proper definitions you could be
irrational while still being logical
that's good in fact you can do that in
programming you could have no picture on
the screen okay and and it's still doing
processes in the console so it's logical
but it's not rational because there's
nothing to be seen there's no object
okay okay
okay well we'll see you again tomorrow
and now you know whether you you know
you can go to the mirror and talk to
them and find out whether you're
rational or irrational you have a
criteria by which to judge not your
yourself but your theories we'll see you
tomorrow
same time same station